Hacksaw rich before I begin this review
I just wanted to say I totally called it
I did a couple videos this year one
specifically called why Mel Gibson
deserves a comeback way before blood
father came out and looking at
everyone's talking about XO rich you
called it bursts Hacksaw rich is a
beautifully told film with some superb
acting especially from Andrew Garfield
it's based on the true story of Desmond
dass a soldier who fought in the Battle
of Okinawa without ever carrying a
single weapon into the battlefield but
besides carrying no weapon he still
managed to save plenty of lives a lot of
[ __ ] lives apparently it's a true
heroic tale and in a day and age where
we're filled with so many superhero
movies it's so cool to see a true story
told of a real life like you kind of
like a superhero in some ways the film
does a wonderful job in terms of its
portrayal of the time its theme its
characters this movie clocks in in a
little over two hours and they don't get
to the war until about like an hour into
the film but that's also part of the
beauty of what makes this film so
powerful if you look at the last couple
directed Mel Gibson features Passion of
the Christ and Apocalypto the main thing
people end up talking about with those
films is how violent those films are yes
they're great dramas but they're think
mainly people think about other violence
because as we all know Mel Gibson knows
how to capture expertly crafted
stylistic and real visual violence
now while hacksaw Ridge does have a
strong amount of intense graphic war
violence it doesn't come until late into
the film and everything leading up to
that is beautifully told we meet Desmond
das played by Andrew Garfield
he's an earnest kind-hearted young man
so goofy so charming he does things
early on in this movie when he's sitting
on Teresa Palmer that one might think of
as creepy but he pulls it off in the
most adorable way anyway when the film
starts off he lives in Virginia with his
mother his brother and his father played
by Hugo Weaving the first act of this
movie kind of did remind me a little bit
of Braveheart in terms of how Braveheart
is also another war film but the first
act is really spent on the romantic
relationship between William Wallace and
the hot chick he was boning at the
beginning of the movie and kind of like
this this is a
movie the main character that focuses
the first act a lot on the romance of
the person who got engaged to you before
the war the person who places love
interest is Teresa Palmer playing
Dorothy shoots use Gradin lights out
she's really wonderful in this too and
the first act of this movie is rather
delightful and most of the aspects yes
it does explore a lot of the dark
elements of Desmond daus's you know
traumatized war veteran father and the
relationship he has with him but the
romance played by Garfield and Palmer is
so genuinely done that you can't help
but really smile like the audience
including myself were laughing at a lot
of great moments in the film and it's a
great setup for a lot of what he's you
know that's a risk by going off to war
the scenes of Hugo Weaving is Desmond
AUSA's father Tom das are very very very
effective normally when I see Hugo
Weaving he just sounds kind of like
another version of Agent Smith even if
he's doing like his British action or
something so kind of just reminds me of
him but I haven't seen Hugo even do a
role like this and it's a very
three-dimensional performance he's more
than just some like [ __ ] abusive
father you can feel the conflicted
layers of love plus the violence that he
had to endure when he was a soldier
there's specifically one scene that
really stands out to me with Hugo
Weaving wear is that the dinner table
the Doss family's at a dinner table and
he's sharing a story he's reliving this
memory of losing one of his best friends
in battle and you know I think I think
it cried a little bit when I don't
remember I didn't like ball but teared
up just a little bit even though the big
advertisement of this film has been Mel
Gibson's first feature that he's
directed in ten years and yes it was the
primary reason for why I went to watch
us in the theaters but like most people
I walked away just really blown away by
Andrew Garfield's powerhouse performance
I just loved the genuine realism he
brought to the role I felt the writing
of the character was great but this
easily could have been put in the hands
of another actor who's really trying to
win an Oscar but I definitely didn't
feel that way about Andrew Garfield's
performance it's very subtle it's
multi-layered and there's a strong level
of conviction in his performance without
ever trying too hard to shine which in
the end makes him really shine I'd say
good amount of the film they thought
maybe most of the film it's spent on
when Desmond das is in military training
we see that he's definitely one of the
more athletic soldiers of the unit but
it's not long before everyone turns her
back on Desmond das when they learned
that due to his religious beliefs as a
seventh-day Adventist that he will not
carry a weapon you won't even practice
with one you know the more I think about
this one just has a a really good range
of characters very well written when he
begins going through military training
we get to meet sergeant Powell played by
Vince Vaughn I was kind of concerned
when they announced that he was gonna be
in it because I was kind of like him I
could be able to get past funny man
Vince Vaughn in a historical war drama I
gotta say this man does a great job like
it was a great casting choice because
while it's a serious dramatic role he
also does have some funny lines where
you're like yeah this is the great actor
to balance this out because it's not a
comedic character but when there's comic
lines in there he pulls it off very well
so it was really nice seeing Vaughn
brought into a really dramatic role
adding a nice personality to the film
captain Glover played by Sam were at
captain Glover Danny Glover Lethal
Weapon co-starred with Mel Gibson six
degrees of Kevin Bacon
or whatever that's called that doesn't
apply to this situation the captain
Glover was played by Sam Worthington he
was a nice addition to the cast as well
I feel like Sam Worthington is a great
actor to me he was the only good part of
Terminator Salvation and after starting
one of the biggest films of all time
avatar it seems like he has really
beginning that many great roles but I
got saying this film he's another
wonderful subtle addition to the cast
and another couple of standout
performers from the group of soldiers
were the actors the the nuke actors Luke
Gracie who you might remember the Point
Break remake masterpiece right there he
plays Smitty Riker I believe is that you
say and everything you did with Point
Break is just totally forgiven because
he does a wonderful job in Hacksaw rich
and Luke Pegler he plays his character
named Hollywood Zane it's so funny in
the film but anyway the drama's spent on
the soldiers trying to get Desmond das
to quit the army before they head off to
war is very very effective like you're
so pulled into the drama of this story
that you completely forget that the
trailer showed you yeah there's supposed
to go to war it's here where we get to
truly identify and truly understand the
level of conviction Desmond das possess
and his values and his morals one thing
I loved about this film was it managed
to actually do a great job at keeping
away from feeling like a a preachy kind
of movie cuz yes this story is
definitely a lot about the concept of
faith what faith means to a human being
but it's not about religion like yeah
they establish a t70 of Venice and he's
reading his Bible all the time but it's
really not about that it's about the
morals the values the faith is one human
being had that made him just as strong
as the other soldiers even if it was in
a different way like that level of faith
is this is also a big story of courage
it's a very inspiring movie this field
to me is not necessarily about promoting
Christianity or becoming a seventh-day
adventists if anything it's promoting
the idea of how powerful it is to stay
true to one's own beliefs but anyway
after that there are the war scenes yeah
they're [ __ ] epic there are some epic
epic war scenes here's what a lot of the
credit really does go to Mel Gibson's
directorial efforts he managed to
capture the battle sequences in a way
that still had the overall tone and
feeling of the kind of chaotic mess that
was like in the opening or any of the
battle sequences in Saving Private Ryan
but he kept the camera smooth enough and
the editing sharp enough to the point
where we could still easily see what was
going on it was an interesting blend and
the violence in this film was truly
effective in the best kind of way I love
when graphic violence is used in a way
that truly enhances the aspects of the
storytelling not where it's like
violence and in story it's like I love
where the violence is it's something
that enhances the whole point of the
story
and here the violence hits you so bad
it's so sudden but that's like our maybe
our 10 minutes or something
you've nestled into the drama like this
moving heartfelt drama throughout then
when the violence kicks in it's so rapid
it's a massive and sudden that you do
get a strong vibe of like what the
battlefield must be like some terrifying
horrific violent experience because it
comes in late into the film that we
spent so much time with characters who
have never been in a battle before that
by the time they get to the battle we're
able to feel their first time
experiencing this and yes one of the big
shoe stories of this film is how this
man
Desmond das was all about like so many
people are killing each other in war I
want to save people I don't want to give
anything away I mean I know you could
probably look up online and find out all
the truth accounts that he did and how
he saved so many lives I didn't know the
details to it but watching it portrayed
in this film when he's being like
full-on hero boy could not help but cry
I kind of want to tear up again right
now honestly it was so [ __ ] moving
like it was so inspiring and just
feeling that level of faith and
persistence just makes you so motivated
and it makes you it really is one of
those things of going against the odds
so much and if I had to like think of a
complaint for the film I guess I would
say it's really just the way it ended
like the ending was good but I would
have liked to have seen the aftermath of
the characters and of the war because
how this movie ends you know without
really giving it's not a spoiler it's
just they cut to footage of a lot of the
characters that we have focused on they
cut to the real-life footage of them all
and while it's great I still was like I
have from my own personal little needs I
wanted to still see the film show me
some of this stuff not cut to like the
documentary footage so while I would
have liked to have seen certain
aftermath moments in the realm of the
film I can't lie to you guys I really
did cry too at some of the document
every interview stuff this film is a
tear fest earlier this year I watched a
movie called la-la land it's not
supposed to come out until the samborose
fortunate enough to see it at the Zurich
Film Festival that I declared easily as
my favorite movie of 2016 and while all
LM might still be my favorite film of
the year because that you just feel a
little better when you watch that but
the more I like to think about hacks are
rich it might take the number one spot
if anything it's definitely a close
second anyway a rating system time it's
a masterpiece chew up on that rating
system and I reject subscribe today and
get accepted I hope you enjoyed this
video
I'm coming up with an outro I'm ending
the video right about